こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんは自分の
お家にお友達やお客さんなどを呼んだこと
はありますでしょうか僕もあります皆さん
大体何人くらい読んだことありますか友達
とか呼んでも23人多くても56人とかで
パーティーをするとかそれぐらいの人数の
人をお家で呼ぶことはよくあると思うん
ですけれども果たして皆さんのお家にお客
さんマックスで何人入るか考えたことあり
ますでしょう
かある
そうですよねみんなそうだと思いますこれ
僕のお家はめ社長の4億円ハウスなんです
けども私ふ思ってしまいましたこのはめ
社長の洋園ハウスに人は何人入るの
かこれ俺めっちゃ気になってました皆さん
もちょっと気になるんじゃないですかえお
うんこれ何平米なんだろう俺ごめんそれも
よくわからないままあの買ってしまったん
ですけどもこのハウスに果たして人間は何
にるのかを今日検証してみたいと思います
昔ね100人隠れんぼこの家に100百
連坊昔この家に100人人を呼んで隠れも
したことがあるんですけども余裕でした
100人ぐらいの人は余裕で入るのがこの
はじめ社長ハウスというわけで今回ですね
とてもたくさんの人に応じに来ていただき
ましたもう続々と僕の王子には集まって
いただいておりますでルールとしては室内
のみにします建物の中お客さん呼んだ時皆
さん庭におきっぱりしないでしょおきっ
ぱって言い方もあるですけども庭にいさせ
られたりはしないと思うので絶対室内にお
呼びすると思うんですよこのうちの室内の
中に何人人が入るのか今日はちょっと実際
にリアルヒューマンを使って実験してみ
たいと思いますでは行き
[音楽]
ましょうあんな堂々と俺に取ることない
から
[音楽]
な
たくさん集まりまし
た今日皆さんに集まったもらったのは他で
もない今から皆さんにはこの試合をして
もらい
ます
嘘です今日皆さんには僕の家に人間が何人
入るかを検証していただきます今日は
よろしくお願いしますちなみに何人入ると
思いますか300300500
50081630170万
170万た俺の予想多分
3000ちなみにですねなぜ女性がいない
かとうするとあのあの色々ね不良の事故と
かね起きるかもしれないので一応今回は
性別を統一して男性でやらせていただき
ます皆さんすいませんでは早速世の中に
入っていき
ましょうはいというわけで最初は玄関前
ですこの空間に人が何に入るかまず検証し
ていきたいと思いますでは野郎ども連れて
きます何人ぐらいいると思うここここだけ
で100を入るすよねこれ100いけるか
なここいけるんじゃないじゃお願いします
願しますさあどんどん入ってきました今度
奥に行っちゃって
[音楽]
ください
人間消ケスだ
[音楽]
ねあれだね満員すぎるとやっぱお客さん
快適じゃないから満員すぎるのはやめとき
ましょう余裕のある空間皆さん余裕のある
空間作りにご協力よろしくお願いします
牛牛詰めじゃないくらいいやじゃないよて
くらいの距離感で快適にうちで過ごして
くださいこれぐらいか
な
フィニ結構入りましたねちょっと数えてみ
たいと思いますはいというわけで結果え
玄関
前に入りました
イこれすごいね玄関前で90だから多分
1000とか余裕で行くんじゃないかな次
の場所行きましょうはい次は玄関の中です
入ると扉を開けて入るとここが一応玄関と
いうことになってますここもね結構人が
入れる気がしますこういう置き物とかもい
てあるんですよねこういう置き物この周り
はでもなしにするかここよりこっち側って
感じかな早速人入れていきたいと思い
ますあ全然座っちゃっていただいて大丈夫
です
よ結構入る
ね玄関前で90っていうのは結構驚きだっ
たんだ
けどそろそろかなストッすっごオレンジの
玄関最大に1待つとこうなるんだ
玄関57人
です
すげえ玄関前玄関中合わせると147人約
150人までえ人待つことができますはい
次はこちら扉開けた奥の超ロング
廊下これ何人入るかな何人入ると思う40
とか40か
[音楽]
俺俺も40だ40っぽい気がするね早速人
入れていきましょうどこどこ
だここまでですあここまではい来た来た来
た使う使う使うマジ使うあ全然使って
くださいはいというわけで入りきたみたい
ですえというわけでえ廊下46人入りまし
たいやすごいな地下鉄駅駅地下のパニック
みたいになってはいというわけで次は
ガレージ何に入るかやってみたいと思い
ますいつもねバイクしか置いてないから
めっちゃ空間に余裕があるんだよな早速
呼んでいきましょう俺バイクに乗って
よ結構すごいなすげえかこいありがとう
ござい
ますいやいやそんなそんなこと
ないストプはいというわけでガレージ92
人入りました
イというわけで次はこちら1回の1番
大きな部屋みんなが編集している部屋です
ねこちらに何人入るか早速人を言っていき
たいと思い
ますりかなスト1回の編集部屋64人入り
まし
たそっかやっぱガレージとかの方が入るの
か車とか置けるもんねこの空間もでも64
に入ること分かりましたありがとうござい
ますはいというわけで次はトイレです
トイレやる必要あるま4回分ありますから
まそうだよななんかそれなりに入りそうな
気もするけどねちょっと俺も含めて検証し
てみたいと思いますレーションしよう
ぜ
ストップトイレ7人入りました
意外と入れるんななトイレも4角回に
トイレあるからどのトイレが1番人入れる
か分かりますねこは7人たはい次は
エレベーターです一応3人なりって書いて
あったんですけどやってみていいですかね
一応なるべく体重軽い方で乗ってみたいと
思います皆さんここ3人上乗るとバゴン
取ってかもしんないですけど大丈夫ですか
大丈夫です大夫大丈夫なじゃ俺も含めて
何人のるかやってみ
ますもう1人いけるか
[音楽]
な6です怖い怖い降りましょ降りまし降り
ましょ降りましはいというわけで1回全て
調べ終わりました1回の合計何人人が入っ
たかちょっと集計したいと思います玄関前
が90人玄関57人廊下46人ガレージ
92人編集部屋64人トイレが7人結構
入ったななんかでも今のところ予想通りな
感じではありますねでエレベーター6人
入ったんですけどエレベーターって1階に
あるのか4階にあるのかちょっと何回に
あるのかわかんないので省いた上で1階に
入る人の
数3562でし
[音楽]
た多いな人が入る予定じゃない部屋なんか
34個取り除いたんでフルに使えばもう
ちょい入るな400人ぐらい入るんじゃ
ないかなとりあえず人が入るスペースには
356人人が入ることが分かりましたはい
続いて1階と2階の間の階段何人人が入る
か調べいきたいと思いますここも結構服
抜けてんだよな何入るか調べていきたいと
思い
ます
さあ何人なんだろう1階から2階の
階段60人入りまし
たはいというわけで2階のこのオヒロマン
ここが多分オレンジで1番大きな場所です
これと100人とか全然余裕で入ると思う
んですよねちょっと
ここお楽しみなので最後に取っておきます
1番大きい場所ちょっと最後に測らして
ください次行きましょう次は2階のトイレ
です1階より狭い気がするよねなんか結構
窮屈な感じがします早速読んでいき
ましょうさ何人入るの
[音楽]
かもうきついかな
1234567人
[音楽]
です狭いように見えましたけどもトイレ7
人だったので1回と同じ人数でした大きさ
同じぐらいなのかなじゃあ次3階行きたい
と思いますはいというわけで3階に行く前
に2階と3階で繋ぐ階段結構大きい方だと
思うんですよ割とヒット乗れそうだよね
ここまでにしよっかここここら辺まで何
入るか試してみたいと思い
ますストップ2階から3回の廊下39人
でしたううわすごいな本当にちゃんと
埋まってる
なやばいやばいやばいどうしましょう
バンって言った
じゃんちわかんなく
なっやばいやばいやばい壊れた壊れたうわ
壊れたななんか風で持ってかれたんか
なえぐ涙の体だ
わ
[音楽]
はいというわけで次は3階のここが多分3
階で一番大きな部屋かな
こちら
え何この部屋何なの何部屋なのこれはま
いっぱいホビー部屋じゃないですかあそう
だねゲームとかするしね3階のなんか色々
ある部屋ですはい結構入りそうな気がして
んだよな多分40ぐらい行くんじゃないか
な
[音楽]
ストプすごいな64人入りました
おこんなオレンチ入るんだここ多分2番目
ぐらいに人が入りそうですね次行き
ましょう3階の洗面所とお風呂場ですはい
お風呂俺最近使ってないな4階のしか使っ
てないんですけどもお風呂場と洗面こちら
ありますここもね結構スペシャルしっかり
グリンで作られてたのでここもね結構
スペースがあるのでそこそこ入りそうな気
がします早速入れていき
[音楽]
ましょうストップかな3階の洗面との
風呂場29に入りまし
たはいというわけで次は3階の廊下です
この輪の感じの廊下結構広いのでそこそこ
人が入りそうですこっち側にも空間がある
のでここもカウントしたいと思いますでは
入れていきましょう
スト3回ろか46人
です次は3階のトイレです果たしてここも
7人なのでしょう
かうわもうこれぴったりだなえ3階の
トイレ7人でした
よしよしよしよしはいというわけで4回
まで来ました今日も青空が綺麗ですね3階
と4回の間の階段果たして何人入るのか
早速やってみたいと思い
[音楽]
ますストップ3階から4階の階段37人
ですさあいよいよ4回です4回行き
ましょうつにきました4回です4回は結構
複雑な構造してるのでどこから取ろうかな
ここよりこっち側
でこにしましょうでは早速野郎ども呼び
たいと思います
[音楽]
来いストプ4回のこっち側の
スペース81に入りまし
たえそんな入んのこここれでもまだ
こっち側もあるから全然まだ入りそうです
ね4回の他のところ行きましょうここから
こっち何に入るか入れてみましょうお願い
し
ますストプというわでこっち側の廊下24
人入れましたうわっしゃというわけで4階
のスイートルームでございますこの部屋に
果たして何人入れるのでしょうかベッドと
かどうしようか
な寝てもらえますかちょっと勘弁して
くださいこうやってやってもらうああはい
座ってもらう分にはねせっかくのスペース
もったいないのでここは特別に立つじゃ
なくて座ってもらいましょうでは呼んで
いき
[音楽]
ますやばいやばいもうやばやば本当に
やばい俺の寝室にこんなに人を連れかんだ
のは初めてだこの部屋に56人人が入り
ました
イはいというわけで次はこちらの部屋
新しい撮影部屋ですねま結構空間空いてる
のでそこそこ人が入るそうだと思い
[音楽]
ますオーですストップ撮影部屋54人です
イエどうも世界黒い布の部屋です果たして
ここ何人入るのでしょうか
カモンいやすごいな完全に異世界に遅え
られた男たちえっと正外1黒い部屋28人
入りましたイ黒い部屋何回か使ったけど
この人数人いるの初めてだはい4回の配信
部屋ですこういうゲーム機材とか種機材と
かパソコン置いてあるお部屋ですこの足の
踏み場が結構少ないのとこっち側見て
ください
[音楽]
結構物で溢れてるので実はそんなに人が
入れない気がしますお願いし
ますトゲーム配信で22人入りました
イ次は4階のお風呂場そして洗面所まとめ
て何人入るか調べてみたいと思いますいや
なんか結構行きそうな気がするけどなよし
カモンストップというわけで4回のお
風呂場と洗面所合わせ
て40人入りまし
たこれすごいいいことって俺女39人呼べ
ますどうも4回のトイレです今のところ
全部7人なんですけどもここは何人なん
でしょう
かこれで7人全部一緒の7人でし
たちのトイレは7人まで入れることが
分かりました
はい室内といえば
そうサウナルームも室内ではないでしょう
かここもちょっと何に入るかっての試した
ことないのね入れてみたいと思い
ます
1234フルス11人11人入りまし
たはいというわけでラスト帰ってきました
2階の大きですこれ何に入るかなすごいよ
ねここ多分いろんな部屋見てきたんです
けど俺の体感は
10050150入る気がします2階の
広いスペース2箇所に分かれててこの
でっかい空間と
こっち和室みたいな空間があるのでここを
分けて調べたいと思いますまずは和室から
行き
[音楽]
ますというわけで和室の
空間52人入りましたイじゃ次1番大きい
空間行き
ましょうはいついに来ました2階の1番
広い空間ここ全部果たして何に入るの
でしょうか早速入れていき
[音楽]
ましょうもう人いないですもう人がいない
すみません実
は150人しか準備してませんだめか
150人でも足りなかったか150人いれ
ば全部の部屋をこう分けながら数えると
思ったんですけどこの部屋に関しては
150人じゃ足りなかったですじゃあ
ちょっと作戦変更して2回に分けて測り
ましょうここでもう線を引いて1回また皆
さん出ていただいて残りの部分で何入るか
で150プスそこの人数でこの場所のニズ
を決めますじゃ皆さん一度ご体しもったい
ねえなでもあ結構開いてますね前の人は
そのまま止まってて後ろの人からどんどん
前に連れてきます150プラス何人になる
のでしょう
かストプ150に入った後後ろの人たちを
前に連れてきました5計216人
イエー
すげえちょっと150人超える部屋がある
と思ってなくて想定外の時代が起きて
しまいましたがすごいなこうなっちゃうん
だオレンジ皆さんありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
[拍手]
はいはいというわけで室内は全部調べ
終わったんですけれどもどうせだったら
どうせだったら庭裏庭と前庭この家にある
んですけれども庭に人間が何入るのかも
一応見ときましょのため集まってもらい
ましたご覧
ください半分だけだ半分しか埋まってない
なんなら半分も埋まってないぐらいかな
これ何人ぐらいだと思い
ますこの半分で170ぐらいっぽいすよね
プラ20人ぐらいでちょうど埋まりそうな
気がします半分で
170に移動し
[音楽]
ましょうまあ同じくらいかなこっちも
170で両面合わせて340次俺あっちも
見てんだよこのこっちの
ロちょっとじゃこっち何か行ってみて
くださいあれちょうどいけそううわすげえ
でこは340+150
で90約500人か裏には500人入り
ますはいというわけで表庭です150人の
を使ってえ3回に分けて取ったら何人入る
かってこやってみたいよこれで150人を
3回合成するとこんな感じ合計450人
ぐらい入ったか
[音楽]
な皆さん今日は本当にありがとうござい
ました
はいというわけで4億円のお家の全ての
場所で何人人間が入るか検証終了しまし
たいやあたくさんの人間に協力して
いただきました本当にありがとうござい
まし
た疲れたあれだけ大人数の人をどこかに
移動させたりまとめたりするのすごい大変
だったんですけどえみんなとてもいい方で
スムーズに進みました本当にご協力
ありがとうございますみんなサンキューな
どれくらい人が入ったのかちょっと結果
発表していきたいと思いますえまず各回1
回から4回まであるんですけども各回に
入る人間の数発表していきますえ1回は
356人入り
ます350人超え356人の人がですね
この家の1階に集まることができます続い
て2階あの1番大きい部屋がた2階は
319人でしたおお1階の方が入るんだ
多分玄関とかがあったからかなそこで1階
がめちゃくちゃ入ってるんだろうな続いて
3階がちょっと少なくて146人ちょっと
少なくないわちょっと少ないの意味が
分からなくなってきたんですけども146
人入りますそして4階が312人結構入っ
たねあと階段とかえサウナ室とか色々
含めるとはじめ社長の4件のお家の室内
この建物の中に
は
1286人1286人人間が収容される
ことが分かりまし
たこの家1000人超えるんだ1200人
ぐらいまでなら余裕を持って入れるのかも
しれませんねいやまあでも生活を考えると
1000人ぐらいか1000人ぐらいだっ
たらまあ23日ぐらいは生活できるんじゃ
ないですかわかんないですけどいや現実を
見ると500人ぐらいか今日やってみた
体感500人ぐらいだったら1週間ぐらい
生活できるかなと思いました無理やり
詰め込めば1286人だから1300人
ぐらいかななかなか入ることが分かりまし
た続いて前庭と裏庭も何人人が入るか結構
ざっくりなんですけども調べてみたところ
前庭には4550人そして裏には500人
合計950人約1000人ぐらいの人が
入ることが分かりましたひょっとしたらね
外に人が集まることもあるかもしれないの
でま外は1000人ぐらい入れるよって
いうのをちょっと覚えといてくださあ来
ないでくださいというわけでえ見長の
4億円の家の敷地内全て合計したところ
建物の中には1286人前庭と裏庭外は
950人合計
2236人の人がこのはめ長の家の中に
入ることが分かりまし
たすご2000人超えるんだ2236人
入るなこんな2000人も入るところにえ
僕
は住んでいるんです
ね
[音楽]
寂しい